Roger stone how are you yeah Roger stone
is here gentlemen
well we're on everything is everything
the strom thurmond used to say people
are very excited about you being here
did you know Strom Thurmond I did what
kind of guy was he because you never
heard terrific things about him was he a
nicer guy than people people thought
he's an old awful races what or was he
not he evolved so when it was popular
and necessary to be a racist in South
Carolina he was a racist but he appoints
the first black US Attorney a number of
African American judges and he always
does particularly well late in his
career you know in the African American
community on the other hand as a lecher
the guy got more ass than a toilet seat
did he really very very active got laid
that right into his 90s Wow for him yeah
go for him hey he was some called in
sperm Thurman for that how old do you
think he wasn't the last time he got
laid the stranger
couldn't tell you but I mean he was a
pincher and a grabber women would
famously not be on elevators with him or
in the car grabbed him he was a grabber
he had like 1930s etiquette I mean
actual US senators it doesn't really
matter what they look like they can pick
up women again look at Al D'Amato I mean
who would go down with that they getting
laid though al D'Amato yeah absolutely
really and is it the power that they had
to when they find that attraction in DC
power thing yeah absolutely
do you think there's any of them it's
fine do you think there's any of them
that don't gie always felt like obama
didn't really seem like he cheated but
most them seem like they do get laid on
the side I do you know any of that that
like absolutely don't cheat well put it
this way
Dwight Eisenhower had a little action on
the side when he was the the you know
commander in the European theater dick
Nixon had a girlfriend in China red hot
readily yeah in fact at one point J
Edgar Hoover and the FBI became so
concerned about this this is while
Nixon's out of office while he's a
former vice president that they know
that Nixon is going to go to Hong Kong
to have a NASA nation with this gorgeous
Chinese woman so they asked British
intelligence to get photos and of course
they take photos of Nixon
this woman through a hotel window you
know hotel room window this is like 1965
Nixon becomes president 1968 Hoover
comes in to see him since mr. president
look at these pictures you have to worry
about this at all they're safe with me
right total blackmail money okay look we
talked about this yesterday maybe you'll
know the answers because Hoover had
denied that there was a mafia and
everybody knows him and Clive had a
whole thing so what was there did Sam
Giancana or one of those guys have
information on him which kind of they
were they kind of had to Hoover uh over
the barrel well he as you probably know
was an inveterate gambler my loved
betting on the ponies particularly and
he would go out to California stay at a
resort that everybody knew was mob owned
and it was widely thought that that's
why I kept saying there was no mafia
extent there is it's a local police
problem and so on on the other hand I
don't think the mob was telling Hoover
what to do I think Hoover was telling
the mob what to do car not protecting he
had his own kind of agenda and they fit
into it okay so it might be more of a
gambling thing we weren't sure if it was
a gay thing right Olson that they kind
of knew you know for though I knew
people who knew Hoover in the day and
they said that he was so discreet and so
closeted that there would be hard to
find the whole idea of Hoover being a
crossdresser that's all nonsense it not
that came out of a very bitter divorce
proceeding between James Rosen Steele
who owned the Schenley liquor fortune
and his wife that's not to say that
Hoover wasn't gay he was just closeted
about it and he wasn't he wasn't going
okay because there's an FBI agent named
Melvin Purvis I think that he had tried
to like guy he wanted to have sex with
they say it was all this weird [ __ ] and
I loved him so you just been fascinated
with political gossip for your whole
life well I think everyone is is
fascinated by gossip
yeah it's show business gossip or
political gossip and show business is as
you know
pardon me politics is show business for
ugly people right I've heard you say
that is accurate
now when you say stuff like that like
you and we watched the documentary that
Netflix did on you amazing by the way I
mean so good but it's obvious that for a
long time now you haven't really cared
whether people like you or not and part
of that is because right you're not
running for office you don't need that
popular vote but now that you've become
so public do you think that it affects
people to be associated with you meaning
if a candidate comes out and it's like
known that Roger stone is his guy isn't
that Roger stone hatred going to come
back and hit the candidate well you
certainly have the possibility that if
I'm involved in your campaign that I
could become a focal point of the debate
and that's not a positive thing which is
why you know I write one of my rules is
use a cut out lay low play dumb keep
movin and then there's the three
corollaries you know so I think yes
look I've cultivated this reputation as
a rogue politics ain't beanbag it's a
rough-and-tumble sport particularly in
the United States it's a contact sport
which is why the Democrats would like me
to be a patsy and pin this Russian
nonsense on me but I've called them out
I mean Feinstein Mark Warner Al Franken
who by the way was never funny as a
comedian unless unless funny as US and
they've all gone on national TV in a
public hearing and they've said things
that are demonstrably provably false all
I'm asking for is the opportunity to
testify in public just as I did and
straighten the record out so is that
what happened with Trump that that you
became early in the Trump campaign you
were a pretty big focal point you were
on the cover of magazines and stuff like
that and there's this story breaks that
either he fired you or you quit or
something but you know the general
theory is that you're still acting in
that advisory role do you realize at
that point I need to be behind the
scenes and in order to do that you need
a different guy in charge I'll still be
on the phone in the shadows over here
that was not my motivation my motivation
first of all I was a paid consultant to
Donald Trump's exploratory effort in
2012 I really wanted him to run in 2012
how did you told him before you should
run the started as early as 1988 again
in 2000 again in 20 you have been about
Obama in 2012 well I thought he could
beat Romney - and one thing at a time
you know I would now say in retrospect
2016 open race no incumbent no
frontrunner and the Republican
nomination not really jeb front-runner
on paper Donald made short work of him
you know mr. low-energy so in retrospect
it was a better year now the reason that
I left and I did resign and I showed my
resignation letter to both a political
reporter a New York Times reporter that
night before because I knew there might
be some controversy about it was because
Donald Trump is his own strategist he
doesn't need a strategist we kind of do
the same thing it's his money it's his
name it's his reputation it's his future
he really had a right to do it his way
he formulated a campaign that was
entirely communications based in other
words he would go in do these giant
rallies get 35,000 people show up
knowing that the cable networks would
show it sure wall to wall that's a multi
million dollar paid TV ad really in a
way right well I also knew that while
they may have helped him to the
nomination they would turn around and
try to screw him in the general election
which of course they did so and also I
had had enough dealings with Corey
Lewandowski to know that he was a weasel
and a liar and I didn't not particularly
talented and therefore I didn't in 64
years old I had no intention of clearing
what I was going to say you didn't want
to remember him yeah not happening and
then as I indicated in the film one of
the requirements was what we need your
strategic advice we'll pay you this
money but you
you have to sign this agreement that you
won't talk to any reporters well that's
like saying in me you know what we want
you on board but you can't eat any food
between now right now and this is what I
did right did you refuse to sign I just
declined I mean I thought I could be
more helpful to krump from the outside
and if you go back and look the day
after I left the campaign I'm out doing
surrogate speaking about why Donald
Trump will be great price tonight I ask
you because you also mention that like
he made short work of Jeb Bush which he
really did and he made the Republicans
he made them all look like rank amateurs
and he made Hillary look like an amateur
how would he have done against a guy
like Reagan or an early 90s Clinton who
were a little bit seemed like a little
tougher politicians would he have had
the same easy time with a guy like
Reagan or would he not have had that
side of it well Reagan is unique but
also the electorate in 2016 is unique
you've never seen this level of anger
disillusionment with all politicians all
parties all political institutions
Congress the people are fed up there
they've never had this level of anger
not even in 2012 right I was building
but it wasn't there yet so and Reagan it
was just a different time although I
would argue Reagan and Trump have many
of the same name slogan well same slogan
and many of the same attributes here's a
difference Crump owns the slogan legally
and if you put it on a hat without his
authorization he will sue you so fast ha
ha ha so did you guys when Lewandowski
takes over do you know that that's not
going to last do you do anything to
sabotage it at all or did he let it he
sabotages himself
yeah Trump lost the Wisconsin primary
then he lost the Louisiana delegates
then he lost the Colorado delegates and
he lost
North Dakota delegates and when that's
happening are you on the phone going
Donald like you got to get rid of this
guy you gotta get somebody else in
you're losing we can't uh no it worked
feel the way around he called me and
said can they really steal this
nomination from me and I said not only
can they but they're going to try look
at the 1952 fight between Robert Taft
and Dwight Eisenhower is a great book on
this written by a guy named
Herbert Brownell who is a former
attorney general who plotted the
strategy the Republican convention is
not regulated by state or federal law
it's regulated by its own rules so the
convention could pass a rule that says
only people wearing red hats may vote
and that would be the rule so it's a
Byzantine process and it was very clear
to me that the Republican establishment
having been rolled over by Trump in the
primaries was going to try to hijack
this in with that odious clown Ted Cruz
I mean you know why people take an
instantaneous dislike today but it is an
instantaneous thing I said they're only
saving time I mean this guy is just a
weasel yeah and he's been a conservative
for I don't know at least 15 minutes you
know they were accused by the way were
you were you accused of being the one
that was these rumors that he had had a
bunch of extramarital affairs and
someone tied your name so that was
unfair of them to title into that he was
upset because there was a National
Enquirer story on this and there's a
quote from me in the story and I did say
the story if this is true it will be a
real problem for his campaign given his
support from evangelical Christians that
doesn't mean that I plant the story in
fact I didn't I think the story came
from Marco Rubio's campaign ah and I
merely commented on to make sure it got
into print yeah that's you furthered it
and if Ted Cruz thinks he's going to run
for president again and these same
issues are not going to come up well I
think he'd be mistaken and distance-r
said the disinformation I want to ask
you about because you mentioned that in
the documentary about how disinformation
is so important and you've only been a
part of it once and that was when you
were very young like can we hang what is
a really really popular piece of
disinformation that has been out there
that you had nothing to do with Lee
Harvey Oswald killed Kennedy and he
acted alone CIA nonsense ridiculous now
when I was always a conspiracy guy you
need to read my book the man who killed
Kennedy the case against LBJ well if I
can get a free copy I don't know I know
where that could be had I
I would read it cuz I but I was a
conspiracy guy and then I started
believing actually a bully OC book kind
of convinced me after all cause even I
didn't know I would see he went into a
debate with the lawyer used to wear the
fringe jackets on this idea Jerry spent
yes Jerry Spence and Bugliosi prepared
for the debate and Spence was coasting
and Bugliosi I think did win the debate
I would have been happy to debate him
having read his book I have debated
Gerald Posner who wrote case closed
very vigorous debate Posner is a really
smart guy he just got a weak case the
forensic evidence the anecdotal evidence
since the Warren Commission is so
overwhelming I'm not sure how anyone
could believe that
Oswald killed Kennedy and he acted alone
and then they say well why did he kill
tippet well he didn't kill pip it the
shell casings found on the ground where
tippet is killed from an automatic
Oswald is arrested with a revolver there
are three witnesses but our my friend
Arlen Specter reply relied on the one
who had poor eyesight by her own
admission and ignored the other two
witnesses who described a shooter who
looks nothing like Oswald in terms of
bills weight height and so on yeah it's
funny I've read a whole bunch of stuff
on it I just I finally found like none
of the conspiracy theories held up for
me they just did mine but what could be
what could be more of a conspiracy
theory than the idea of a bullet
changing directions three times I've
also heard - I can't I can't do a
lawyer's job of explaining it but I've
heard the quote-unquote Magic Bullet
theory explained and how the diagrams
get it wrong and where he was actually
not sitting where a lot of the diagrams
show he was sitting and in 78 when they
did the House Select Committee on
assassinations I think that they said
that the acoustic evidence was
questionable but Michael Baden those
guys kind of said that the medical
evidence held up and that mean that was
that was just what convinced me I have
never relied on the acoustic evidence I
thought it was weak interesting but weak
here is something that is undisputable
Gerald Ford at the request of J Edgar
Hoover with a pencil
changes the chart from the autopsy
moving the wound from JFK's upper back
to the base of his neck to accommodate
the Magic Bullet theory the New York
Times reported this it was not learned
until those documents were Declassified
in the 70s and they asked for why he did
it and he said well the country needed
clarity no I think the country needed
truth but there you have it in his own
hand he didn't deny it I find that
pretty compelling
I can't debate X I haven't heard it so
yeah I can't read my book yeah Nicole I
read it when you you know you're talking
about Jeb Bush a minute ago and to me
like that was probably my favorite story
of the whole election cycle was watching
this guy who had been sitting there for
what 16 years waiting for his turn like
like you know knows campaign slogan his
father father tell them it's my time
yeah you know he watches his brother who
I don't think in his head was ever
supposed to be president until he
decided to be present and go okay you
know what I'm gonna help him get it and
then I'm gonna wait and then it's going
to be my turn
yes and everybody before Trump gets in
is saying well of course it's going to
be Jeb people are already complaining
another Bush Clinton and other Bush
Clinton is and just like that Jeb Bush
goes eight he gets destroyed and you
could see it on this guy's face like his
his whole world view of what what life
was going to look like his destiny you
you and tackled Trump changed his entire
life span yeah no I think there's no
question he thought that this would be
very easy the vaunted bush machine which
really had a stranglehold on party money
mm-hmm
the problem was that he had no spark he
had no energy it was like I want to be
President because it's my turn right
because I have a vision for the country
I remember him saying to Trump one of
the debates you can't insult your way
into the presidency oh really
and EMEA I think he's very hypocritical
he's a giant drug warrior and given his
own past is both a user and a pusher you
know I think it's pretty disingenuous I
think I just find that as I do
John Kasich very phony but as a man
looking at another man like just
emotionally going through this was there
any part of you that was just like I
took it away from him or was it
prideful like I won you probably were
taken that we probably be in war at
Syria already probably given them the
no-fly zone which is the open invitation
to the Russians to have a thermonuclear
war didn't we have enough of that I mean
I really think that karl rove is a
genius in the sense that he was able to
sell within the republican party the
notion that george w bush kept us safe
you know he didn't 9/11 happened on his
watch
yes which trump pointed out really soon
yeah virginia base yeah and the truth is
that there are some 22 individual
complaints to the Florida Department of
Law Enforcement about these guys in
Sarasota who are training at a flight
school and seem to have a great interest
in learning how to take off but no
interest is how to land and they do
nothing they don't ever send that to
why'd they do nothing yeah I wasn't two
of those guys turn out to be 9/11
hijackers I wanted to ask you to
evacuate the documentary covers so much
and lobbying you know is to me one of
the things that Trump has said we have
got to drain the swamp and the lobbying
is terrible and your group was kind of
admittedly like very responsible for a
lot of the lobbying of foreign
government and you said you kind of have
no guilt about that or you feel like hey
you made money on it do you but do you
think the lobbying has gotten to a point
where it's just it is no conscience to
it at all or how do you feel about it
well first of all it has been this way
for a very long time I didn't invent
lobbying tommy tommy the cork Corcoran
an associate of Franklin Roosevelt
invited invented lobbying when I was at
black man important stone we only
represented governments that were
pro-western and pro as they say well you
represented you know torturers because
Marcos and so on they were allies of the
United States we never represented any
Eastern Bloc countries nor would we have
the work that we did in Ukraine came
much later and it's not lobbying at all
Paul Manafort worked for a recognized
democratic political party that one and
all
election our government recognized that
party and recognized the outcome of the
election I actually worked against mana
for in a small splinter party that was
also pro-western and pro
rata their legislature in order to be at
the table so this notion you were
helping the Russians take over Ukraine
please it was a democratic election no
no dude but do you think Trump's stance
against it like no I think I think he I
think he's right look I was never
particularly good as a lobbyist that's
not what I that was never a great love
of mine but it's a perfectly legal
process does money infect the political
process absolutely is everything in
Washington for sale absolutely you have
the right lawyers the right lobbyists
the right amount of money and you have
politicians like Chuck Schumer with
their hand out yeah I think you can
pretty much buy anything who is the
least corruptible person you've ever
worked with or no new jersey governor
Thomas H Kane why was that just an
enormous amount of integrity justjust
you couldn't buy him you couldn't boss
him he would always do what was right do
you think Trump went in with a bit of
like paint Obama said transparency it's
hard to be transparent do you think some
kind of went in not understanding how
difficult it was going to be to to weave
his way through things and get him done
or do you think he had the right amount
of knowledge of what it was going to
take to get things done you know you've
had guys who were president let's take
Nixon who sits there for eight years as
vice president and watches he knows
where the levers of power he knows the
ten most important jobs you gotta fill
first and then the next ten and then the
next ten he understands as a system also
true of Lyndon Johnson who had been vice
president Trump is not a career
politician never claimed he was he is an
executive and is executive you got to be
a quick study and a decision-maker
gather as much information as you can
study a subject review your options and
make a decision some of our presidents
like say Jimmy Carter their problem is
they were really smart but they could
never make a decision they just did it
probably had superior command of the
material but just wasn't
decisive krump is decisive krump is a
quick study he never claimed to know
everything but he can learn I think
there is a you know there is some
shakedown period here in which you've
got to get your sea legs interestingly
enough both Clinton and Carter in the
first six months of their presidencies
were considered a disaster right you
know and then they got it together
putting the serve two terms do you are
you uh it was was the firing of Comey on
your advice that's what I've read
I was certainly in favor of firing Comey
I wrote it tweeted what about the timing
of it uh I think Jim Comey had worn out
his welcome and I think that the hearing
on May 3rd was kind of the last straw
he's a guy running between the between
the the raindrops and he'd become
unaccountable he was interested in
investigating some crimes but not others
I mean the Clinton Foundation is not a
charity this is a slush fund for
grifters this is a vehicle for the
facilitation of multi-million dollar
bribes
if the people running the Clinton
Foundation Republicans they'd be making
license plates in prison right now why
the IRS has not pulled their tax status
is incredible to me but maybe they were
too busy harassing right-of-center
nonprofits that they thought were too
political so it was time for Comey to go
he had no public credibility left
recognize that in the election roughly
five days before the election he reopens
the investigation into Hillary's email
because he's received six hundred and
fifty thousand emails that Huma Abedin
has forwarded from her State Department
account to a private secret yahoo
account which anthony weiner has access
to so call me who took two years to go
through 33,000 emails comes back two
days later and says we've looked at all
six hundred thousand right nothing there
well my source is in the NYPD who are
the people who found this in the midst
of their investigation
- anthony weiner they tell me and I have
seen some of it the the emails
constitute corruption self-dealing dirty
tricks in the campaign that Hillary very
clearly involved in uh and then Kony
comes back the Sunday night before the
election says we've looked there's
nothing there you notice there's not a
big swing back to Hillary Clinton commis
worn out his welcome nobody believes
anything the guy says anymore but how
much influence how much influence do you
have right now on the president are dead
do you call him does he call you and you
say look I understand people because
because of the timing of the call me
thing obviously a lot of people are
going to associate it with the
investigation with the Russia with all
this stuff so that's why it's a
questionable decision to make that
decision now the firing of Comey is not
going to end an inquiry into whether
there was Russian collusion I believe as
the President believes that this is a
canard
this is a first a charge hurled by John
Podesta
who wants to distract attention from the
fact that he and his brother are very
active in Russia on business matters
there's the uranium deal the gas deal
the banking deal they're the guys making
money from the oligarchs around Putin
and Bill and Hillary are getting
speeches giving speeches paid for by the
click around Putin so what better way to
distract from all of that then accuse
Donald Trump of being in bed for the
Russians this is a scandal in search of
evidence where is the smoking gun I
don't think it exists why would and why
won't he and it's like you know I I
don't know how to feel about Trump's as
think about my life things I don't but
why won't he release his taxes is simply
because it would just shut people up if
there's nothing there it would shut
people up and it does seem that there's
the president we kind of have the right
to know that like I believe in your
privacy when you're the president we
have the right to know I think a lot
about you and the fact that he's not
doing that seems you seem shady and it
doesn't send any reason for well if you
go back to look during the campaign I
was in favor of him releasing his taxes
because I honestly believe there's
nothing there that's particularly
interested he made a lot of money and he
did have a big deduction that became
clear was perfectly legal it was funny
how some people tried to imply that was
somehow
tax evasion that's why the system works
if you have losses you're allowed to
write the mantra and he did I would like
to see him do that to release his tax
returns to make it go away but he's a
very stubborn guy it is interesting to
me that that issue killed Mitt Romney
killed him who ultimately folded and
released them never really heard from
but it also seems to be he like you said
he's a stubborn guy but he also is a guy
who likes to win and as a guy who likes
to win if there's nothing there and it
would shut them up
what better weapon and shoved that in
their faces and there's nothing there I
mean that's the ultimate victory it's
not something I can opine on because
I've actually honestly never discussed
this specific issue with him but it's
clear from his public comments that he
feels strongly about how often you talk
to him from time to time that's all you
say yeah look I've never been willing to
characterize the content or the scope or
the frequency of our conversations
because I'm smart to know that if I do
they'll end up the president the
president has the right to some
assumption of confidentiality that you
can talk politics or war about anything
and he's not going to read about it on
front page of the story wasn't let me
ask you about Bill Clinton because in
your in your book called the making of
the president 2016 you specifically say
we talked about remember Jim when we
talked about the black kid who said he
was Bill Clinton son I remember I huh
you flat-out say he is definitely Bill
Clinton isn't my view first of all I've
interviewed his mother his aunt a number
of other people in his life they've all
passed polygraphs it is clear that
Clinton is supporting the kid
financially from the time he's born to
the time that he becomes president it
also helps that he's a dead ringer for
Bill he says Bill's charisma he's got
Bill's gift of gab he's very charming
was the woman who said the bill [ __ ]
her in the bushes yeah we talked about
that quite a bit he'll just jog and buy
a decider in the bushes in the process
yes my dog and in 1988 there's
very extensive attempt to foist a DNA
test on the public the star tabloid
owned by a Clinton crony and whose
general counsel at that point is David
Kendall Clinton's lawyer obtained the
DNA evidence from the famous blue dress
which is attached to the final summary
of the impeachment report from the
special prosecutor to the Congress the
problem with that is it takes two
different DNA tests compared to legally
determine who a parent is so they only
have half a test the other half even
though it says in the text that they
conducted both the results for only one
test is attached
therefore utilizing that data could only
be inconclusive right not enough
information today that Danny Williams is
bill son and it's not enough to
information to say that he's not Bill's
son
which is why Danny is you know is
preparing to file a paternity suit in
Arkansas to try to get to the bottom of
it let me just finish by saying this
Danny Williams works in a meat packing
plant by day works in the 7-eleven at
night to provide for his five children
his father is worth four hundred million
dollars taking out hunted elk time for
Bill Clinton to step up and do the right
thing now there was also questions -
about you tweeted about I guess the
Podesta
hacked emails before they became known
that's only photo it is untrue okay I
hat I did tweet on August 14th now
recognize the context the Democrats are
laying the wood to Paul Manafort my you
know an usher in my wedding my friend of
40 years accusing him of all kinds of
malfeasance in Eastern Europe I have
seen the opposition research on John and
Tony Podesta and they're very active
money-making activities in Russia
involving oligarchs close to Putin and
on August 15th I say Podesta's time in
the barrel will come I never mentioned
email anywhere you didn't say Wednesday
or no no that's a different that's a
common issue we'll come back to it
the conjecture is us don't knew about
that no I knew that he had all these
deals I knew that that would get
Republic publicly reported and between
August 14th and Election Day there's
over a hundred stories on their business
dealings page one of The Wall Street
Journal Bloomberg News etc etcetera
cetera so I never said you know his
emails will provide any information
never had any reference to his emails
because I didn't know his emails would
be hacked until they were published like
everyone else I did have a source tell
me in early August
that Julian Assange who I do not think
is a Russian asset who I believe is a--
is a whistleblower is a journalist that
he had a treasure trove of information
on hillary clinton and he would really
sit in october now if you go back and
look what he leaked says this in a tweet
on July 31st I hadn't seen that at the
time so it's not exactly a state secret
to say that I knew the scope and the
specifics and the timing other than
October early October my source tells me
it's going to happen Wednesday the fifth
and on Wednesday the 5th of October
Assange has a press event and he says
I'm going to have disclosures every week
for the next 10 weeks and he does that's
it but to say that I had some special
knowledge of the material that's false
and what about the cameras or a
conversation that they said you were
just praising the gusoff or the hacker
what is that I just said on this call
you gusoff err 2.0 is a prominent hacker
who has claimed that he hacks the DNC
documents gives them to WikiLeaks
WikiLeaks publishes them I reported that
and wrote a piece on it for Breitbart
news on August 5th
two weeks later I read on Twitter that
he's been banned I don't believe in
banning anybody I think everybody
including the craziest Democrat
left-winger nutjob should still have
access to Twitter and Facebook and so on
I'm just not against censorship I'm a
First Amendment guy let your ideas sink
or swim on
all right so I had a brief private
direct message exchange with him which
I've now made entirely public in which I
say hey I saw that he got reinstated I
so I said hey congratulations always in
a Twitter DM oh so so based on the
timing though my exchange with him
happened six weeks after WikiLeaks has
already released the documents and
that's the only exchange in my hab so
how could I have colluded with him on
the release of those documents unless I
owned a time machine do and I checked we
pulled in his time machine is not yet
perfected okay there's pizza Gabriel
don't know what your God look I do think
that in the wake of the Haitian
earthquake that there is a child sex
trafficking ring operating out of Haiti
would tacit at least look away of the
government there I do think they're
trafficking children around the world
I do think unfortunately pedophilia is
popular among certain upper echelon
strata of society particularly in Europe
but I don't I've not read enough on this
to form an opinion I think it is
unlikely that anyone was running a you
know a child trafficking ring out of the
pizza place in DC and they wouldn't have
said yeah they wouldn't have said let's
have pizza yeah I don't know enough
about that yeah but you're not willing
to said it's not true you just don't
know if it is I have no idea and can I
see that Roy Cohn real quickly we live
throughout our short Lea but when you
look back on Roy and and that do you
think that he was a good man or he was a
bad man there's aspects of both he's
very complicated I mean I saw Wayne
Barrett who is an indebted liar and
makes a bunch of stuff up in the
documentary but he took an evening at
the reporter yeah yeah I went through
his four part series on me with a yellow
highlighter 69 absolutely flat ass lies
with one source I mean the National
Association of journalism requires two
sources for a blind quote but not way
and bear it so he gets a lot wrong but
Roy was a very tough very tenacious very
vicious guy when he was fighting either
to survive or on behalf of his clients
he was Donald Trump's lawyer
I met Trump through cone cone could also
be very sentimental very loyal you know
when my my old that one when one of my
aunts died unexpectedly was like hey
take my car out to Connecticut keep it
for a couple days I'll take cabs but you
know you can move your family around
just he was a he was an anomaly it was a
paradox
he was a very complex and intense guy we
have to wrap up in like a minute
I was going to ask here your life
personally and professionally I think
that the Roger stone that we now know
was kind of shaped after the scandal
involving you putting swinger ads for
you and your wife in swinger
publications which you owned up to which
I think was a strong failure to do most
people don't own up to those things when
they're caught they're caught at the
time I frankly I wanted to preserve the
feelings of both my parents and my
grandparents who are all still living
sure but I've never been a moral
majority Republican yeah I've never been
a wear it on your sleeve Christian
evangelical I'm a libertarian and a
libertine
I'm trisexual I've tried it all okay
whose business is it I'm not running for
public rice right no I'm not I'm not not
and I'm not claiming to be some moral
Paragon cool it straight back page notes
later what you do what you do in your
bedroom who you choose to love what you
choose to smoke what you choose that's
all up to you but as a Washington guide
as a part of you in hindsight go yeah
maybe I shouldn't put a photo up there
no because you know what ah Julie
Atwater is a great friend of mine and I
watched him brown-nose the bushes into a
becoming Republican National Chairman I
was just a never a guy who could pretend
that I believed things I didn't believe
I was not a big Bush fan father or son
and I couldn't tell George Bush boy
you're really the smartest guy in the
world I just couldn't do it it's
hypocritical I am what I am
you know I'm a libertarian I'm a
libertine I'm not running for public
office I'm not looking for approval I'm
a great believer I'm a real conservative
meaning I want government out of the
bedroom and out of the boardroom great
and we should have more time with you
this was great yeah Roger so there's a
couple things to promote the making into
president 2016 is your book they
literally just gave us this today but
the documentary on Netflix is what
you're here for
it's great it's so good I wish I get the
link very late last night and some part
of it it's it's excellent water Carlson
and it says yeah I think every president
every person in America needs this book
the making of the president 2016 you get
it on Amazon or Barnes & Noble but the
Netflix document it's not a love letter
it's not a hit job you know I'm a
straight down the middle
seems like it's pretty it's love-hate
and it seems like it's a pretty honest
picture of you which i think is great
some of the most incredible suits I've
ever seen
yeah that's riffing I got to be honest
you do you look like a million bucks and
I'm looking forward to getting my free
copy of your book that is what's really
important day of K book and when does
the Netflix thing premiere so any more
12 hour well thank you for coming